how's going bros my name is perd Pam and
welcome to iPods
what how fast how fast I can I can what
how fast you interrupt my Friday video
for this sanic fast you know that's not
a sonic outfit right how do you know cuz
it's not blue dosh line race me parrots
how am I gonna race you this arrived in
the mail congratulations you have been
selected to compete in the first-ever
Anki Drive battle Grand Prix nine robot
race car commandos will enter only you
will win
are you battle ready
that's right [ __ ] I told you our sanic
Fez
bros I've been invited to the Anki Drive
battleground Prix it's gonna take place
in LA so I have to travel there and
battle eight other youtubers yeah good
luck with that [ __ ] shut up we have the
same voice it's kind of weird once I'm
in LA I'll get to practice with a real
on key team member a real one after that
we get to compete on who's gonna be the
champion if you want to find out more
check out this link or in the
description hopefully I will win and
make you bros proud here I want you to
have this make me proud [ __ ] make me
proud that's all for me for now I need
your birth support with this as always
I'll end up with the brofist stay
awesome route